de fuit pas ne pas de nausées ne fut pas
y êtes
j'attends conjure laisse-moi tirer les
cartouches il ya une jeune fille qui a
fait son apparition dans l'émission
c'est gisèle gisèle sachez qu'ici
gilles verdez jean michel maire et jean
luc lemoine dans une moindre mesure lui
fait plus de l'amitié mais il peut
chauffer ils ont envie d'aller plus loin
avec gisèle vous allez avoir trois
prétendants qui vont devoir placer cinq
mots dans la conversation en combien de
secondes les chérissent et 50 secondes
voilà donc les mots que vous devez
placer donc vous les voyez ici à l'écran
vous les voyez chez vous gisèle tu sais
que depuis de la première fois que tu as
vu dans l'émission j'ai pensé à toi tous
les jours pratiquement je m'imaginais g
au brésil en train de me baigner dans
les eaux turquoises en train de pêcher
la rascasse porte à porte et un peu à
manger le soir qu'on serait sous une
paillote ne crois pas ce que vont dire
les autres j'ai pas du tout de maladie
même si j'ai 50 ans voilà je suis là bob
la prostate est en très bon état
gélifiant cause en tout les orteils mais
moi je vais t'offrir des enfants
geoffrey une vie une vie où ce qui sera
pas du film et qui nous dit qu'il sera
fait d'horaires là ce qu'il me voilà
maintenant j'ai mon bigorneaux
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
voilà ça va pas être facile
allez-y jean-luc gisèle tu vous pouvez
enlever les musiques de merde ça nous
disait je crois que ta place est pas ici
moi j'ai envie qu'on parte tous les deux
qu'on soit sur la place qu'on fasse du
naturisme et tu vas vite voir que avec
toi mon mât chipolatas va devenir
concombre vraiment et je te promets une
chose mon amour pour le voir tu vas pas
besoin d'un microscope
je sais que j'ai un peu vite mais je
t'aime euro id
[Applaudissements]
oh
à
c'est bon les gars là on l'a ou pas
casser mais c'est qu'il verse la faire
le con donc la cgil bernès
est-ce qu'il a une chance de détrôner
jean luc lemoine ou pas du tout et là la
chance parce qu'il y avait aussi un côté
très rapide
[Applaudissements]
vous êtes gâtés on les a faits en
fonction de vos balais disais pas disait
regarde moi regarde moi je n'ai pas
d'herpès regarde moi tes mains donne moi
tes mains gisèle donne moi tes mains 3
milliards dogues se prosternent à tes
pieds mais c'est pour voir tv rue moi je
veux simplement gisèle tenir ta
maintenir ta main même pas toucher ton
oignons je te ne fuit pas ne pas de
nausées ne fut pas disait je t'en
conjure res mois tirées les cartouches
et les
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]